good morning millennials
happy tuesday happy day where we are the
furthest
ever possible day away from next year's
yom kippur we will never have this much
time between this yom kippur and next
young people
enjoy it jewish toasters relish it good
morning good morning wow i can't believe
it's tuesday i guess that's like a small
gift from
yom kippur being yesterday but that's
where the gifts start and end because
yesterday was a rough one you guys like
the
fast was difficult but it was made more
difficult because not eating for
that long gave me a headache which i
like still have right now
and that's where it gets tough because
it's like even when i broke my fast
which usually
it brings it all back together it it
never ended it was like a never
ending touch yeah i mean i hate to be
like that girl but i'm never that girl
where it's like
i actually probably have a harder time
fasting than most human beings like for
some people like not eating for a few
hours it's like a part of
every day like they always forgot to eat
never have been made will never be me
i can't be that [ __ ] we'll never be
that [ __ ] but something yesterday like
i had like kind of an easy time like i
was like joking around like i was
annoyed but like i wasn't to the point
where i was like gonna faint
i did get like a little bit of a bad
mood towards like seven o'clock but
honestly it was probably the easiest
i've had in my adult life i think that's
also because we didn't go to temple
because of coronavirus virus so we were
able to just like i literally laid in
bed
all day it was so crazy so yes on the
hunger front
it was all right but then on the
headache front
that was yeah that was a new front for
me i would say the not going to temple
is like a game changer i mean
we've never not gone we always go and
we'll probably we'll never not go again
no we'll probably never go again because
now that we've had this experience like
it's so
it's the worst part like it's so long
and quiet and everyone's breath smells
but it also does give you something
to do during the day but it also i was
like so
aware of every hour passing no but it
also adds like a level of meaningfulness
throughout the day because you're like
physically atoning for your sins
so i did feel like a little guilty but i
wasn't really mad about it i just like
it was a really hard one and i just
can't believe we have to do that once a
year like for the rest of our lives
no i was thinking that yesterday i'm
like i'm going to be like 50 and doing
this
well well there are exemptions like for
the elderly
so 50 is not open actually yeah but like
the older you get
the more eligible you are to aging out
of the fasting process also if you're
pregnant you don't have to fast so
that's just something to think about as
you plan the rest of your
life totally like try and plan your
pregnancies around the september october
areas
totally um how was your weekend
otherwise my weekend was really good
i watched a lot of content like caught
up on so much stuff that i'm excited to
talk about
and we had a great gno and so it was
like a really just a great weekend
just great yeah it was a good
combination of like
having drinks also relaxing i started
mad men i too watched a lot of content
it was i also started yellowstone
at your behest me and ben did and
i just can't believe this is the show
you've been talking about requires a lot
of patience and like
you might not even like it until five
episodes in but you're not gonna love it
until maybe season two and like
in the beginning there's no character
that you like and you're like why are
these people like
you just find it all so strange but then
like something happens and you just
start to love it
well i just like couldn't get on board
with the bangs
yeah well eventually like you will
really like her it takes so much time
and like all
all of that down time where you're like
just trying to figure out what's going
on like
pays off there's a great payoff well i
just
i couldn't get into it it was like a bad
use of my time ben kind of liked it so
he went in the living room and continued
on with it
and i started mad men which was such a
better show it really reminds me of
marvelous mrs nasal
just in the sense of how they really
capture like a decade yeah um and i
really like it i'm really enjoying it
surprising that you like it i loved it
it also makes it
really challenging because i just don't
like um
peggy yeah what's her character
elizabeth olsen no peggy
what's her name in real life elizabeth
olsen it's not elizabeth olsen that's
mary kate's sister elizabeth holmes
no it's um who's that elizabeth it's
right on the tip of my tongue
scientology girl yeah it's um elizabeth
elizabeth arden no no no
that's the smell yes it was
right on the tip of my tongue elizabeth
moss i just she like
borderline ruins shows for me like even
i kind of liked handmaid's tale but like
she was like truly the main character
yeah um so it's hard for me and i and i
think the show like i think she gets a
bigger and bigger role
like if what i barely know about it is
that like she's like important and
there's like this scene where she's
walking down the hall with her box and
it's like important so like
we'll see but i'm enjoying it she does
get a bigger role but she also becomes
much more
likeable just like okay but like beth
dutton is not played by an actress who
you'll never be able to get behind
that's the thing yeah no i feel that
it's a tough one um but it's an ensemble
cast you can like focus on other people
yeah
it's really excellent i love january
jones she's
beautiful everything of the sort it's
like one of the greatest characters
of all time and all i want is like dawn
to be nice to her i know
and he just like won't like give her
like anything so troubled
so troubled yeah she doesn't even know
you know right
like she thinks she's married like a
nice guy yeah who works in advertising
and he's just like has like a double
life i'm also excited to start watching
it because i would like to see harry
hamlin
he's not he's barely in the show oh
really like yeah on beverly hills says
it makes it seem like it's like
his show he eventually like comes on in
a season and like has a role but like
he's probably number like 35 on list of
names
yeah oh my god lisa like really made it
seem like he like replaced
jon hamm no no for don draper like
eventually he gets like a decent sized
role
but he's like not the man well i've
actually never seen him at a madman
right i've never seen him act in
anything yeah he's a good actor that'll
be interesting
you don't even notice him you're not
even gonna notice him he's such a
nothing oh wow okay wow tell me how you
really feel
um i watch i finish it's creek which
we'll talk about okay i have so many
thoughts
and i caught up on lob island and i feel
like there was one other thing that i
watched but i can't remember oh
potomac obviously oh yes we will discuss
that in our tv recap segment
so we'll discuss it all in our tv recap
segment yeah i think we should cut you
we have a very busy episode today
we are sitting down with simon huck um
he just launched a new podcast and his
co-host will be
here here with him too if you're
watching this on youtube it'll be on
another video on our channel and if
you're listening to this podcast just
keep listening it'll be at the end of
the episode
yeah very very exciting time in studio
guest for the first time in like
eight months very exciting it's a very
big day here
and i feel really good knowing it's like
simon from judy
because he'll be totally taken care of
oh for sure but i guess without further
ado we should get into the fast side
stories that you need to know before you
wake up and take a bite out of your
morning toast
oh one thing did happen over the weekend
that i forgot to talk about in our
weekend recap segment i got a call from
my doctor
she said the flare-ups are back [ __ ] she
told me not to be alarmed
that there's a really easy and safe cure
for my rdh and that is
letting everyone know that today's
episode is brought to you by simplify
a lot is up in the air right now
especially when it comes to our personal
finances
so much of how we've changed spending so
much of how we spend money has changed
i know a lot of us are ordering in more
we're ordering groceries we're not going
out to dinner we're not going out to
bars
and a lot of our finances are changing
and there's a lot of uncertainty so it's
never been a better time to start
planning
your financials because whether you're
anticipating a major life change like a
wedding or a move
or you just want to get a jump start on
planning the future simplify makes it
easy to track your spending so you can
budget smarter
after trying dozens of apps the new york
times wire cutter picked simplified by
quicken as the best
budgeting app because it doesn't make
you choose between simple and effective
you can start healthier financial habits
and achieve your long-term goals with
simplify
they make it easy to see the big picture
stay on top of your spending and
save like a pro you can say goodbye to
surprise charges from subscriptions you
forgot you signed up for
such an important yes that is i'm the
queen of just like pressing yes and then
forgetting that my seven week trial
you know was over um so apps like this
really help you stay really organized
when it comes to subscriptions
they make it easy to monitor all of your
spending so you're never in the dark
simplify is all about balancing today
and tomorrow other financial apps
primarily track what's already happened
in the past
but simplify helps you find get
personalized tips insights to help
develop a healthy long-term habit
and stay on top of your finances now and
in the future
they focus on insights and not input
because other financial apps feel like
they guilt you for not meeting your
goals
but there's no judgments but simplify
they won't overwhelm you with every
dollar that you're off by
you can see why the new york times wire
cutter is calling simplify by quicken
the best budgeting app out there
start your 30 day free trial of simplify
today when you download the app
or visit simplifymoney.com spelling is
s-i-m-p-l-i-f-i
money.com if you want to start your
30-day free trial of simplify today
download the app or visit
simplifymoney.com
check it out you know these are
uncertain times your financials should
not be uncertain
love it sign on get your financials in
order
yes sign on simplify first story a
little follow-up to last week's story
but demi lovato is completely
embarrassed and
rightly by max eric's behavior
after their breakup one word what am i
going to say my favorite word
that but disgrace oh for sure this
is a disgrace demi lovato is ready to
move on after fiance
max eric showed his true colors this
weekend following the news of their
split max took to social media to reveal
and since deleted instagram posts
that allegedly learning of their breakup
through a quote tabloid
soon thereafter a source told e that the
actor was lying about such claims
additionally he accused demi of allowing
him to be bullied by her fans
he then asked please stop trying to
thank you next me
a reference to ariana grande too
invested in pop culture but if max was
trying to win the pop star back the
social media posts are not doing him any
favors
a source exclusively tells e news demi
wants no contact with max at this point
she's completely embarrassed at the way
he's been acting and putting their
relationship on blast via social media
she wants nothing to do with him so
there were also other instagram stories
that he left
up yeah and let me read you some of that
please do this is just like a notepad
moment where he just typed out some text
to this moment we haven't spoken over
the phone
we haven't even officially ended
anything to each other literally
i'm hearing y'all with real i'm here in
real time
say they're still engaged wait and this
is how you're gonna actually i'm about
to really blow your mind
i'm here in real time with y'all i love
demetria
and just want her to be healthy and safe
that's the first one
i just have to say like people who call
their significant others like by their
full names just like
to kind of like stake a claim on them
the girls do it all the time it's like
benjamin it's like his name is ben you
know i've literally never called ben
benjamin like one time even when i was
angry i hate when people do that and
he's doing that like
demetrius zach has never called me
jacqueline in my life
i don't even think he knows that that's
my name 100
so it's like i i just [ __ ] hate when
girls do that like
you know what i mean like andrew david
roman off the third get in here
here's another one if you're reading
this i love you always
unconditionally no matter what next one
he's listening to don't forget demi's
best song any screenshot of the spotify
i've respected and loved demetria since
i was 15 and my friend samara
who recently passed away took me to her
concert
there's just so much going on i don't
even know where to go so much going
there's another one there was also the
one where he
said like um don't thank you next to me
like i have a job to do like there's
people relying on me with like families
oh no complex okay here's another one
he's listening to get back from demi
lovato's album don't forget
demetria is the best female vocalist
alive and
everyone should know it and we by the
way we know that don't worry then he's
listening to catch me also a great song
she inspires me every day and is an
incredible human being
i know it's not her writing these
stories it's a machine
i love her unconditionally demetria i
love you always and forever the demetria
i honestly forgot that that was her real
name
me too this is so wild another one he's
listening to anyone by jamie lovato
give demetria the grammy she deserves
all caps
thanks smiley face oh my gosh and then
finally he encourages everyone to stream
her new song okay to not be okay because
okay that's what like
uh her instagram is like full of promo
for that it's like not even anything to
do with max which i'm sure it's
driving him insane he goes go stream
hashtag okay to not be okay
the lyrics are incredible her voice is
impeccable
keep it at number one forever it's what
demetria deserves
i love you i literally can't just okay
here's the thing like he's not
wrong about these things no of course
that she's just so crazy imagine
breaking up with your
there's so many things to imagine here
imagine breaking up with your fiance and
then like going and listening to all of
their music as like your breakup
playlist
that's depressing yeah imagine this is
the part that i can't get over like this
guy
is the definition of a thirst monster
like star
[ __ ] like social climber social
climber
and he wound up engaged to like a major
major
a major a-list forever pop star yeah
and he blew it like i i understand why
he's this mad
all of his hard work his whole life
people like that
don't blame people like that don't get
as far as they do and then only to [ __ ]
it up at the engagement
no so that's like so crazy and so now
like all of this is like his star
[ __ ] colors like coming out
you know and he's hot at the end of the
day like just to stand
yeah and i think at the end of the day
he also whatever his motives were like i
think he also truly wants to be a star
himself
and it must be difficult to go with
living one living with one of the most
famous
women in the world like the planes the
trains the cars like all the fancy stuff
and i was like back to flying coach you
know
yeah yeah that's probably at least for
me like that would be the hardest like
adjusting back to normal life
well yeah i totally agree i'm so glad
that
demi got out of there and that now she's
embarrassed so like there's no chance of
her going back there's no regret or
should i have like what if because now
she knows like what he is and that's
really he's just a stan
this relationship though like as much as
i love demi like will be a [ __ ] stain on
her record for a really long time
for a break i'm trying to forgive and
forget i don't know i'm trying but it's
i don't know how we got here you know i
know you know what i feel like we're
gonna
get like a documentary or an episode of
like american greed one day about this
how he swindled her how he swindled her
yeah and i think it's just really
interesting like how you can go from
stan to fiance
you know it's inspiring for all these
fans out there a hallmark movie
you'd love to see it from stan to fiance
beautiful
okay well demi do you think you've got
to dance no
from fan to family oh yeah i guess that
makes it sound too nice though
yeah um okay next up another crazy story
kyle richards alleged ring thief says it
wasn't
her this is such a weird series of
events i still have
so many questions about this story and i
just love how tic tac of course played a
part in it okay so diana french is a
retired pharmacy clerk from l.a who went
viral
while her hands did after for some
strange reason actress diane keaton
shared a photo of her hands
um calling diana's black nails too much
and claiming she's a fortune teller
well that's that is the strangest thing
yes
diane keaton took a picture of a random
woman's manicured hands because she just
thought they were interesting she was
wearing a lot of rings and big
long black fingernails yeah and so she
took a picture of it put on her
instagram and said that the woman was a
fortune teller
and we know now the woman wendy is a
pharmacy pharmacist okay
anyway kyle richards saw diane keaton's
post
and believe she recognized one of the
rings diana was wearing as her mom's
stolen ring
which got swiped back in december 2017
when when kyle and her husband's home
was hit by burglars which we all
know that was a crazy time teddy
mellencamp had just done the security
in the home it was like in lim it was it
was strange and she was in aspen
after diana went viral for all the wrong
reasons her granddaughter took to tick
tock to clear her name
she also defended herself by going on
inside edition with even more proof the
ring belongs to her
including old photos of her wearing it
and the original appraisal from 40 years
ago
kyle had gone public with her search for
the stolen ring but to be fair she never
accused the woman of
theft she thought she might have
purchased the ring from a pawn shop and
was going to offer to buy it back from
her
so it seems like the fortune teller
pharmacy clerk is in the clear
but now she's waiting on an apology from
kyle richards and diane
keaton i think she'll be waiting quite
some time i don't know if she's
necessarily deserving of an apology let
me tell you why
one she was never named nobody it was
just a pair of hands nobody knew that it
was like
diane from you know north carolina like
nobody accused her of anything and kyle
did not accuse her
she thought like when her stuff was
stolen it was sold onto the black market
somehow made its way into a pawn shop
and like she never accused this woman of
stealing anything so first of all she's
not getting an apology i don't know if
she necessarily even deserves one
and the granddaughter is actually the
one who put the target on her
grandmother's back by letting everyone
know oh this is my grandma her
her name is blah the story is very
confusing for a multitude of reasons one
diane keaton and the pharmacist name is
diana one
two dan keaton said it was a fortune
teller and the woman claims
she's not a fortune teller she is a
pharmacist like that is the most
confusing part
yeah but maybe she has a side gig you
know
her daughter like twyla in cafe tropical
trying to raise money for a new
dishwasher yeah but her granddaughter
said she's not
a fortune dollar well maybe she doesn't
tell her granddaughter everything maybe
you know maybe yeah this is such a crazy
turn of events because like i just
when i first saw the story i was like oh
my god kyle's found her ring
period i thought it was 100 and that we
were going to like they were going to
trace the ring back and find the
burglars and she'd get all her birkens
back
and her mom's jewelry but no just like
of strange return of events it's like
two women have this ring
yes but i guess like this woman's
grandmother and kyle richard's mom were
probably of the same-ish age and like
these rings were maybe like trendy and
being sold
at some place you know yeah it's like
not that crazy that they would have the
same ring no it's not that crazy at all
it's just a crazy story it is and you
know what if she was good at her job she
would have seen this one coming
oh [ __ ] you're right also i would love
to hear from diane keaton like how she
got dragged into this mess
yeah that's what you get for like going
around and taking pictures of people's
hands diane
yeah but like she posed for the picture
so when she saw it
come up yeah or maybe it was a picture
like diane found on pinterest like she
was looking for nail inspo yeah yeah it
didn't the picture didn't scream
pinterest but i i know what you mean
yeah anyways what a crazy weird story
very strange like the converging of lots
of different worlds
yeah okay next up very exciting mariah
carey spills all on overbearing marriage
to tommy matulla sneaking around with
derek jeter
and more in new memoir i will 100
be reading this book mariah carey's
memoir comes out this month it's called
the meaning of mariah carey
and she apparently allegedly is
telling all this lead up to her book is
giving me
very much just an open book like press
tour vibes
and they're going to suck me in i'm
going to read it and it's going to
change my life and i'm
so excited i'm excited because i know
what i've been ready to do for a while
i've been ready to stand mariah carey
like
i've never gotten there because i love
her adore her but i've never been like a
huge huge huge fan
and i think this book could bring me
there and i'm ready to get a better
understanding
of the meaning of mariah right totally
and this article is like some of the
biggest you know bombshells from the
book
and if you want i'll share them but if
we're both going to read it like maybe
we should experience them on our own
okay i mean i'm fine with that i really
like so this story is mostly just to let
you know that
the book is is almost here yeah and when
whenever people ask me like what my
favorite genre of book is like i don't
know how to explain like that it's this
it's
celebrity book by memoir right see a lot
of celebrities have written
books and sometimes they're like
attempting to be like aspirational
or like storytelling and in like a
nonfiction kind of way
i love a tell-all i love a juicy gossip
open book andy cohen diaries brandi
glanville books like
this i have a feeling is gonna be
sensational if i know mariah she works
with like the best writer ever
and i just can't wait yes she worked
with michaela angela davis on the book
oh she's
not pretending she wrote it um no and i
think
like i'm sure it went down like most
celebrity books go down like where
they do it together yeah but most
celebrities like have a ghost writer and
they pay them and you don't know that
yeah but i think we know like well of
course you know what i mean like yeah i
so i don't this is exactly what i would
picture picture is that she's sharing
her story
someone else is helping her write it and
we're gonna get the best possible book
out of it and that's all that matters
yeah that's all that matters and we're
gonna get a best seller out of it for
sure
oh i mean yeah for sure i'm really
excited i gotta
queue it up on my kindle oh i'm gonna
buy a hard copy
oh very nice because i support the book
industry okay cool so we'll
we'll save the bombshells but i don't
even know she dated derek jeter
i know so it's going to be like all this
good so we just reported on this story
just to withhold the facts from you no
we reported on the story because we
haven't spoken about this book yet yeah
and i remember in the lead up to jessica
simpson's book there was literally a
story
every single day which was enjoyable but
since we both wound up reading the book
it would have been nice to just enjoy
them so this story is just to let you
know
the book is coming i need to get the
exact date but it is october so
that's like so soon october is this
weekend yeah that's crazy
it's that's crazy that's crazy what a
waste of a year
what a geez totally like a just complete
and total wash
total last i thought this was going to
be like one of the best years of my life
like well you know what for me i feel
like every other year
is like a good year like not bad yeah
yeah
but like great year a year and 2019 was
such a great year it was amazing and
then i was like
and things were looking good for 2020 so
i was like there's no way that 2020
could like topic because that's just not
how like life goes for me
and look you're right actually so 2021
is going to be it like i swear i know
everyone's like waiting for 20 21 but
but i just like i guess the odd number
of years i just that works for me
i feel it works for me okay next story
very exciting
news every day is like new either
pregnancy news baby news yeah
birthing news today's news game of
thrones stars kit harrington and russ
leslie are pregnant with their first
lesson
russ leslie oh my god that's amazing and
also this weekend sophie turner finally
posted some
pregnancy pics of her that joe had taken
when she was pregnant she looked
amazing and jackson brittany had their
gender reveal it's a boy
boy we had the vanderbump girls all
together so
lala's having a girl stacy's having a
girl and brittany's having a boy oh
perfect
yeah really they're gonna fight over him
um
yeah that's so cute it's very very sweet
so russ leslie
leslie is pregnant with her first child
beautiful jon snow's
do you think she just walks around
thinking like i got jon snow like that's
what i would do i would wake up in the
morning be like
jon snow's mine [ __ ] um yeah i mean
i'm sure she's excited and i feel as
though he's excited too because like
ygritte was
really otp for him you know he never
really bounced back no he didn't like
that was the wildling that stole his
heart
he tried to date his aunt but it didn't
right think of how desperate he was like
he was
so you know heartbroken from ygritte
that he actually fell into the arms of
his aunt like
that's how you know he was so sad
to go from rust to yarn i'm so so happy
for them
i say to my nephew theo theo get over
here
can you come here hi cute come on hi
cute you look so beautiful
come yeah anyway so this is just like a
great story
i missed the days where we would talk
about game of thrones every single day
no those recaps were like so
funny finger in the bum like yeah but
you know
now we have other things like fifth and
final story that'll lead us into a tv
recap because we both finished shit's
creek
the real shit's creek motel will soon be
up for sale the rosebud mozart
motel yes it's a no frills small town
motel that a family moves into after
losing their wealth and soon this
television famous property can be your
own the property it's not a set
no the property that plays the role of
the rosebud motel at least the outside
on shit's creek um is poised to hit the
market
soon wow yes it'll be up for sale next
month the owner
told the press the actually buy it
who the rosebud motel property group you
know what i was thinking um
okay so like this is interesting and
cool but and let's just get into our
yeah it's just a gateway into our
recap of shit's creek but i was actually
thinking
that the rosebud motel group was such a
great idea and that really is something
that
hasn't you know the hotels haven't
really been monopolized and treated as
boutique hotels and they really are such
like a
staple you know it's a small town
experience yeah and it and it really can
be
and i think that like their pitch was an
incredible idea and i actually think
that eugene
levy which is like what i'm realizing
their last name is not like
yeah not leavey and so that's going to
be a hard transition for me but i'll try
um eugene levy and dan levy or maybe
like anyone in their family
should take this up and like go out
there and make rosebud motels like the
hilton of motels like
that could be you know the next act for
them and they would have all started
from the show and they would be
billionaires and then the show would
just be amazing marketing
yeah for rosebud motel group let's talk
about the actual
final season because i just loved it i
don't know if i loved it so much because
i was just relishing like these are my
final moyer rose moments but she was
just
on another level i i my absolute
favorite part of like where i was like
actually laughing out loud
was when they went to the new hotel and
like they loved that presidential suite
and like moyer really wanted to move in
there
so she was doing everything she could to
make their current room like look like
[ __ ] like she couldn't fit through the
door frame and she fell on him
she was being so funny like i enjoyed
the season so much but i really enjoyed
moira like she
is why we tune in yeah and knowing that
they swept at the emmys for the final
season made sense because the show has
just been like
this little gem but the final season was
like everything that was great about all
the seasons wrapped up into one so it's
not like they just won because the whole
show is good like the last season was
really
everyone at their best i loved it so
much i actually started watching so i
hadn't watched the season finale from
last season
and when they did um cabaret oh yeah
oh my god and the show was phenomenal
and you saw everyone in the audience was
like
and i felt like that was like at the
epitome of shit's creek where it's like
everything is a piece of [ __ ] but then
it comes together and it's actually kind
of nice
yeah and when like patrick and stevie
and like alexis were like
in cabaret i literally had chills up my
like spine because it's like it starts
at such a joke in the town hall
but it came together so wonderfully i
loved alexis and i feel like this was
like a hard season first she like just
couldn't get
her life together yeah i mean she really
had to learn how to stand on her own two
feet and even though i
ship alexis and ted i don't know that i
loved that journey for them
um i i i liked where she ended up i
liked where all the characters ended up
i think it was
so good and i'm really glad that i
watched it it made the day go by because
with all the emmy accolades i was able
to put it all into context and did you
watch the episode that was like the
best wishes oh so you know how game of
thrones did that documentary about
the last season they did something
similar and so you've got a lot of like
the back story behind everyone's casting
and you know what last season meant to
them and how much this show has just
like had this like cult following and
grown
like just from being like a small
canadian comedy show to being like
completely mainstream it's crazy by the
way that like how far they've come when
like they literally exist on a channel
like most people don't have or they've
never even heard of
yeah but they were it's all so deserving
and to talk about like how they
saw the show in their heads and you know
i just watch the show and i don't think
about what they're trying to do
but everything that they were trying to
do just completely
worked yeah um when it comes to casting
did they address in their um little
why the daughter wasn't alexis why
twyla's character wasn't played
no why alexis's character wasn't played
by the girl who played twyla
because most people actually can't
haven't figured out
that eugene levy's son is dan and his
daughter is twyla a lot of people
actually think alexis is his daughter
yeah so they did not address that and
that to me is something that just like
sticks out they said that they had a
hard time casting alexis they saw like a
hundred different actresses
before they met annie murphy and just
like liked what she brought to the table
and so i don't know why i try like
because twilight being in every single
episode so
why couldn't she be alexis that does
feel like
an elephant in the room yeah and then
also they had this like mini emmys party
and like twyla wasn't there
really yeah are you sure eugene levy i
watched his speech he thanked like his
his um daughter who wasn't there oh
interesting i thought that was annie
murphy who wasn't there and then she
accepted her award and i was like but
she is here no anywhere if he was there
everyone was there patrick was there
ronnie was there i want to talk about
the wedding like
i would you cry of no no i was
sobbing because i was also hysterically
laughing at moira like
she went the first time when she entered
the room in that pope outfit like she's
just too much
and then her weird inflections like
she was honestly being too much like i
was so overwhelmed with emotion i didn't
know whether to cry or laugh but like i
thought it was so sweet
when the jazzy girls started saying that
i
was it was breathtaking i was like the
[ __ ] jazzy gals
the [ __ ] jazzy gals
that's the name of today's episode
what's so amazing about the jazzy girls
is they literally
rehearse so much throughout all the
seasons and you could tell and you could
tell we never really got to listen
to them but it felt like an episode of
glee i was waiting for them to start
singing
bruno mars 100 because that's what
yeah i think i want to marry you yeah
because that's like the vibe i was
getting me too and they wound up
singing um that song that
patrick's saying you're simply the best
yes and it was so good
i started crying when alexis and david
were walking down the aisle
me too i was like i was i don't know i
was just like so emotional and then when
romans was like
they look like a husband and
eugene was like they do yeah wait so it
was just like the perfect encapsulation
of what shit's creek is it's like so
funny these two people look like husband
and wife they're brother and sister
and it's also so emotional yeah it's
that is shit's crazy
i was hysterically laughing when alexis
like right before they walked out she's
like david
it's taunt on me that this is a wedding
dress and she was just being so funny
and i really felt like
that wedding scene in that episode in
particular but really like the wedding
scene
was perfect television like it was just
it was the perfect formula for how to
make a tv show end in like such a
meaningful way i did have one gripe with
the ending which was like
okay we've seen them like at their
lowest for so long
oh man excuse me i'm getting choked up
could we see them could we get two
minutes devoted to like
them i would like to see moira thriving
again like i would like to see alexis
living in new york i would like to see
the house that
patrick and david moved into like i
would have liked five years from now and
it's like
they all come back for thanksgiving at
david's you know like something
well i actually think they left it open
to a reboot like
soon later they could bring the show
back in like three years
and it would go it would be so well done
because i think
with david and patrick still being there
and the apothecary like
you could even have like new people who
move to shit's creek and then be like
sort of background characters employees
i think twyla bought the cafe yeah
alexis could always like move back
in five years after she's like made her
mark and be with ted
and maybe moira and eugene want to
retire and they retire
at shits creek like and they built a big
house and they build a big house so i
think that the way that they left it
that they ended it was perfect because
it was just like this moment in time for
this family
to come together and realize what's
important in life and that's what the
show is about
like this family finding their way back
to each other and now that they're out
of shit's creek we're not gonna follow
them the show is shit's creek
but i don't know something about them
ending it after six seasons when it was
like
at the height of its popularity is
really an interesting
choice and they talk about that in the
like documentary sort of right i've
heard david say like
most shows don't get the option to go
out on their own they're either
canceled or it's like the ratings drop
no one really gets to write their own
ending it's always like timing just like
shoves them out
yeah or like they drag it out so long
they kind of ruin it yeah
so it's this perfect gem of a show that
is perfect yeah and they're not like
dragging out how long they're living
there for you know there was a time in
like seasons three and four or whatever
where it was like
oh these people live here now like
they're never gonna leave and the goal
is not still to get their money back and
move back to new york or l.a
yeah and then i realized like david like
bought a store here he can't just leave
like some of them have roots here
some of them don't so i think them
eventually getting and i shouldn't be
chosen like johnny rose is like such a
great businessman that he can do it
again
that he has all this business prowess
and
his book his book i can't but i do i
think it ended really perfectly
while also leaving it open to be picked
back up
and some point in time and also like
victor garber just being in the final
season was just
everything of the sort um annoying that
it's not on netflix yet like i don't
know how many
most americans are watching it like i
had to watch it on my spectrum app with
commercials and it was the same three
commercials like i was literally going
it was
it was driving me up a wall like truly
city and um
southwest airlines like it was the same
two commercials multiple it wasn't
everything
it wasn't for larry yeah so funny like
larry air is
rural juror and also herbert lingard
herberblinger oh and by the way he made
another return too that episode was
so that was that like the herbert
lingard episode was when i was like
this is the funniest thing i've ever
seen and moira in the beginning i like
didn't understand
why her obviously because she's hard to
understand she's
yeah she's so multifaceted and that when
i that's when i was like oh my god this
woman
and the documentary thing sort of
answered our questions about
is moira catherine o'hara is catherine
o'hara or moira
and i think it's a character it's a
character for sure
but moira would not have been who she
was if she wasn't played by captain
power like
they said that catherine o'hara brought
the wigs and brought the accents oh
and gave this woman like a personality
that was hadn't been like fully fleshed
out in character development i will
watch that
little documentary it sounds fascinating
it was really cute um
so it's like a like sad that it's over
i'm glad that i watched the final season
though because
it's a perfect it's not something you
should leave open-ended like it is just
a perfect moment in time show
and it should be watched from beginning
to end agreed and not be sad about it
because it really is like
it's untouched like it's perfect yeah um
now we're gonna dive into our official
tv recap segment where we
cap real housewives of potomac which was
on sunday we didn't get to recap it
yesterday because of yom kippur
and just a reminder that the tv recap
segment is brought to you by our
favorite new brand of cbd
new x new x's mission is to provide
their customers with the highest quality
products at a reasonable price
with years of experience in sourcing
manufacturing and development
their goal is to make cbd accessible to
the masses we never sacrifice quality
and all of our products are natural
pure and tested so my favorite product
from new x and just cbd in general
is cbd gummies but i find it really hard
to find a good brand of cbd gummies
because they're
not always super well made and you never
know how much cbd like dosage is
actually
in each gummy within the pack so the new
x ones are great because they have
like they're super great tasting they're
actually delicious they have 15
milligrams of broad spectrum cbd per
gummy they're vegan and they're made
with all natural ingredients they have
no artificial colors flavor sweeteners
and they are th thc free they're perfect
for people who want a fun and easy way
of taking cbd or have never taken cbd
before maybe just want to dip their toe
in the pond
um and it's a consistent dose every time
which is really uh
i think the biggest selling point um the
cbd gummies are 9.99 which is a really
good price they also come in different
variations of cbd products they have
shots
which is like a 150 milligrams of
caffeine and energy blend
with cbd so it's perfect to take in the
morning those are also
vegan non-gmo they come in the mango
flavor they're really really good
um actually keep one in my purse pretty
much at all times it's a great
alternative to coffee i don't drink
coffee so cbd is a blessing
and those are only four not 4.99 so i
feel like new x is a great company one
because
uh they just have a broad range of
products for cbd and
it's really reasonably priced without
like compromising the quality of the
taste or the actual cbd
um if you want to check it out visit
newex.com which is nu-x dot com
to purchase some of their great products
you can use the discount code toast for
20
off for a limited time so that's new x
and you x dot com use the code toast for
20 off for a limited time
um check it out it's fabulous sign on
get your cbd
okay so real house is a potomac kind of
this was the episode episode
and i just wanna i want it to be said
before i start complaining about other
parts of the episode like my jaw was
legitimately on the floor like
i knew there was a fight and bravo
always hypes things up but like this was
actually
under hyped like i couldn't believe i
was watching and the fight
was still going on and she still had her
hair
hand in her hair yeah um yes i agree
with you it was like a big fight and not
overstating but then on the other hand
i feel so many different ways about this
spike and i was reading a lot of tweets
and like different opinions about it
on the other hand like it was hair
pulling and
glass throwing which is standard for him
we've had it in the house
not it's always a big deal when it
happens but it's not uncommon yeah
not uncommon like not a bigger fight
than anything that we've ever seen
but just last season like danielle staub
and margaret joseph had like a very
similar sort of fight
um yes but to me this one seemed to last
longer
yeah i get like the other one was like
more i think actually margaret joseph's
one was also one of the worst i had seen
yeah that was yeah but they they it was
glass throwing and hair
and hair pulling you're right and that
was a [ __ ] wild hair pull
yeah danielle stabbed like honestly
unacceptable yeah
so it was it was crazy
obviously you know everyone is upset
with monique because they feel
that she started it she made it physical
candace definitely provoked her
verbally yeah did you see the video that
i sent you i did and i had already seen
it
people are really slowing down people
are dissecting this fight there's
so much going on put hands on who first
because the two of them are going at it
wendy's trying to stop it robin and
giselle are trying to stop it so there's
so many
hands flying even before the fight
starts
yeah it's like in this in this one
moment where it's like the
the dime flips and it's like really the
fight starts everyone happens to just
get involved at the same moment
and it's hard to see who put i mean
in my opinion monique started because
she was flipping her hair which
is not technically a fight but you can't
touch someone yeah i agree with you
she's flipping your hair flipping your
hair flipping your hair and then
candice pulls her vest yeah which makes
it a little bit more of like an
aggressive fight and then monique goes
wild
so yeah it's like where do we where do
we where does the star fight start
yeah so if just watching the episode i
was like okay monique started it but
then watching a slow down video
it's she starts with the hair flip but
candace put her hand on like
her body first and then it just
it got i mean but the worst of it all
was when monique
had candace's hair and was just
going at it like i i couldn't believe it
like but then also
candace throwing his lips on her face
and lip is bleeding yeah so
it was just and it was just so crazy
that that big of a fight started from
the conversation that was had which was
like
nothing crazy nothing crazy and i also
was
reading more and people are convinced
that there's obviously more to this
than just worse kenneth inviting cherise
to a party and from what i understand
candace was like aware of the rumors
that charisse was starting and it wasn't
just that monique
um there's a lot of things it was that
monique's baby um the baby that she just
had
is not chris's it was that um she didn't
have a miscarriage
a few seasons ago she had an abortion
and just like
these really damaging rumors about her
family
and not so just bigger than right well
that makes sense because
things aren't adding up yeah and i saw
this video where can
where candace explains like sort of what
these rumors and then at the dinner
table when they were having that party
for ashley
she pretends like she didn't really know
that there was so much beat between
monique and cherise
all i'm saying is that again i don't
think that we're getting the entire
story because
that was a disproportionate reaction to
the fight that we think that they're
having yeah but we can only dissect what
we're given and even though
she's not always my favorite robin just
like really summed it up perfectly she's
like
candace is annoying as hell and she runs
her mouth
but monique is wrong like regardless if
we're dissecting the fight it's very
clear that monique was the one who took
it
way too far like she was the one who
needed to be you know held back the
producers locked her in a room and they
got candace out
and i pains me to say it because i am
team monique
but she was wrong she was wrong she
wasn't right she was she was
not right she wasn't right i'm
struggling with this one
i know you know and i'm sure there's
more to it because we need to dissect
what we've been given
that there is more to it um i think that
candace
is so annoying and sneaky i agree and
she puts on and she's literally like
this they're you know so close to each
other and she's like drag me drag me
drag me
and she did and she did no but there's
just like candace is definitely annoying
she's a pageant girl like she puts on a
face and
she there she's definitely sneaky and
whatever and
i mean and i just hated this episode
because it made me feel bad for candace
like she
really got hurt yeah and the rest
to the head the rest of the episode was
strange because it was clear that the
woman they were just
avoiding would not film with each other
and everybody sort of needed to
cool off after the fight and figure out
you know where do we go from here and
and next week it looks like there's uh
a sitting down and candace is gonna
attend and the other women are like to
monique like pretty much like we don't
want to work with you anymore
and we can't we can't be associated with
this yeah
um which i'll have to see in context i
just think
that that's a bit extreme you know i
don't know
i feel like the real housewives of
potomac take their jobs really really
seriously as like
really powerful strong black women and i
think they probably
felt like this was like a step down and
they don't they don't want to be
associated they take they take their
roles as like role models
really really seriously and i feel like
karen huger and giselle are like kind of
like the oldest and wisest in the group
and they really feel strongly about like
staying above the fray and i kind of
agree with them
i i i unders i agree with that too um
but then i was watching some clips on
twitter where people were like showing
instances where like gisele and robin
when they showed up at ashley's
restaurant and like we're saying that
they
literally showed up to a place of
business like while it was open and like
saying they're going to drag her
um over the wood like through the over
the bridge or through over
and through the woods and it's like
right no it's honestly like
moral um relativism like we're saying
this is bad but like we've done bad
stuff too
yeah and so i i think that i i want to
see just
you know monique just to pop like
obviously
move past it and i don't know how and if
they can get past it i do think that
they can
but i i feel like next week's
conversation like
if monique it seems as though she's not
remorseful but i don't want to judge it
based on the preview
agreed so i'll have to see what happens
from there but
it it was just i also feel like there's
something they're not telling us
yeah of course and that's kind of been
like a theme throughout
um certain housewives this season like
in new york there was a lot they weren't
telling us about tinsley and duranda and
it's kind of annoying
yeah don't make us guess like yeah we're
investing an hour a week in the show
like give us the full story just because
something didn't happen on camera like
doesn't mean you can't
talk explain it bring it up talk about
it and then integrate it into the
storyline
you know um the rest of the episode was
a little bit boring i did think that
uh it really was very interesting not to
see like gisele's
tripped it like her dad yeah that was
the other way i kind of
loved him like i'm the same way it's
like all right i'll say
i like it to your face but like when i
when i leave i'm just gonna like say how
i really feel you know
yeah but i think also he was trying to
make it work
and he just was fed up and that was so
crazy when he was like hot miked
but it was like he had the wherewithal
like people who aren't on reality tv
every day like don't understand how mics
work and they think if you say something
bad they'll just take it out like
he had the the understanding to get up
off camera have them take his mic off
but couldn't wait five seconds for his
mic to be actually off
to start talking [ __ ] right and like for
them to ask
gisele how many children does he have
and then
us to find out it's six to seven is
crazy i knew he
had um like children with other people i
didn't know it was six or seven
no yeah i mean how would we how would we
know so it's just a lot for any person
yeah but watching the girls in the
restaurant was awesome she has great
daughters
she has great daughters and i
i thought that was just like a great
scene for the family and then it was
also
crazy it was crazy yeah um so that was
like a good pick up at the end of the
episode because
there was a lot in the beginning a
little boring like the post-snap and
karen's marriage problems
get a real therapist what was the radio
i was doing in your house as a therapist
like
so crazy and when ashley was like you
know she's
off the hook now right with the michael
j like she's she came in letting
everyone know she had an open mind and
she thought it was going to be like
her like everyone's going to come after
her ask her a million questions and like
nobody cares and somehow the evening
turned out not to be about her
yeah i just i'm honestly with every
episode like really
my respect for ashley is like i know all
the way up here i know
like talk about open book honest owning
it
housewives he is all of those housewives
i totally agree so
i'm looking forward to this conversation
with monique next week and all in all it
was a good episode i mean that fight was
just [ __ ] crazy
yeah it was but i think we can come back
from it i think we can too
like other franchises have come back
from way worse i totally agreed
um so that's not on that anything else
we want to say before we wrap up enjoy
this next segment with simon hawk again
if you're listening as a podcast just
keep listening
if you're on youtube go check it out it
was so funny like
maybe one of my i mean we haven't had a
guess in like all year but one of my
favorites this year
totally and i think our only other guest
this year was simon you know we had a
few we had like tyler c
yeah yeah no i'm kidding but it was
really um really really funny so check
it out enjoy it
enjoy and we'll see you tomorrow and
we'll see you tomorrow thank you guys
for watching listening to the morning
shows monday morning show where we
deliver the past life stories that you
need to know every day on youtube
monday through friday so if you're
watching this on youtube please feel
free to subscribe and give this video a
thumbs up
we're also available as a podcast and
we're podcasting we found that spotify
itunes stitcher public video i already
cast box all the places
so ever you listen to podcasts find us a
morning toast leave a five-star review
about a beautiful stunning it's where we
are
we love you guys so much have an amazing
day and we'll see you tomorrow bye